hey everyone i'm rob greenfield
hey i'm eric joseph lewis from plant
path nursery and today we are going to
teach you how to plant a community fruit
or nut tree and
what i want to say first and foremost is
don't be intimidated planting trees can
sound like this big thing but it's
actually really simple and we're going
to show you how simple it is today but
also we're going to share some tips that
are you know a little bit more
of that mid-level or advanced as well to
really try to have your trees be as
successful as possible but bottom line
planting community fruit and nut trees
is easy and we're going to show you how
to do that today so the first step to
planting these bare root trees is to dig
your hole
i really love digging forks because they
help us to
create the hole without creating any
soil compaction
if you only have a shovel definitely
definitely use a shovel and that's one
of those examples of like a little bit
of a pro tip that'll help things just do
a little bit better
and if you don't have a digging fork i
highly recommend looking around your
local thrift store or yard sale i find
these things for five bucks all the time
she's got the solutions
the solutions are always there with this
very simple
okay
all right so as you can see we're not
digging a massive hole we got a little
tree here
pretty simple yeah 8 to 12 inches is
about all it takes with most bare root
trees
so we're going about a foot down um and
then how about width how far are we
going here
uh about 12 inches across so about 12
inches deep and 12 inches wide
and one thing about planting community
fruit trees is wherever you are you'll
be working with whatever soil there is
there so you know here in
asheville north carolina we're working
in this spot with some clay
but also some sandy soil and one of the
keys to success is making sure to adapt
to your environment and and working with
the soils that you have
so the next tip is when you're putting
your tree into the hole you want to make
sure that the roots don't hook upwards
because this upward pointing root is
more prone to rot and disease and those
diseases can then find their way through
the entire tree so make sure that all
your roots are pointing down you'll see
our trees here are soaking
in a half filled five gallon bucket of
water and why do we want to have the the
trees soaking and how long do we soak
them for
you never want to soak your trees for
more than six to eight hours so that's
really just to super hydrate the roots
prior to going into their holes
and ideally you'll be planting
on a rainy overcast day like today
shortly after a rain or just before a
rain
but if you're in an area without rain
you got a plant without rain simple as
that
and the next step so now i've got the
roots all carefully positioned and
they're all pointing downwards and now
we're just breaking up the native soil
and putting it right back into the hole
that it came from
making sure to keep the collar of the
tree
uh just at the level of the ground and
what you'll notice here eric said native
soil what native soil means is whatever
the soil is here so we're filling this
hole back in with just the soil that we
dug up we're not adding
anything to this hole except the tree
and the native soil
right from where we dug it out one
little tip is when you're digging your
holes
don't spread your soil all over because
then you won't be able to get it back
you'll see eric made this neat little
you know pile right next to the to the
hole so that way you can easily move the
soil back into the hole
another note is you'll see like with
this clay that we're breaking it up into
small pieces um we want to do that so
that you know you're not having these
big air gaps or anything like that in
there and as we go we're gently kind of
tamping the soil down
so that those air pockets that rob just
mentioned
are gonna get pressed out and
settled in you'll also notice that we're
leaving a little bit of space here near
the top because our next step is gonna
be weed suppression
the tree is now planted and it was very
simple but i just want to re-share a
couple of points
first we only filled the hole in with
the native soil so we didn't add
anything to the hole
um as we were doing that you know here
in clay soil we broke that up
uh and then we only buried the tree up
to the collar you don't want to bury the
tree deeper that can
ultimately result in your trees dying
and that's one of the most common
mistakes i would say new tree planters
make right yeah absolutely agree so
making sure that you're planting the
tree at the native soil level at the
tree collar and then on one last little
tip um what we did is we pulled the
grass back
around the tree some
just to uh
prevent this grass from being able to
overtake the tree so that'll help you
with reducing your weeding later on and
now the next step is what's
above the native soil and uh so what's
next
next is um the same reason that we
pulled the grass away uh we want to
suppress weeds and prevent other things
from growing immediately around this
chestnut because they will
compete for both water and nutrients and
that can lead to your tree drying out in
prolonged droughts now my favorite
material to use for weed suppression is
definitely
scrap boards from lumber mills but you
can also get burlap sacks from local
coffee roasters or the most common
resource for most folks is going to be
cardboard and so we'll just put this
cardboard down
so that it's right up
to the edge
of the tree
and make sure that it's as tight as
possible to the tree
and then next we want to give our tree a
little bit of fertility just to give it
that boost and that extra head start as
it's establishing
there you see that's about
uh two gallons
of
good nice rich compost
and this is uh
this is an excellent kind of soil and
the reason that we put this on top
rather than mixing it into the hole
is because we want these nutrients to
percolate in slowly and we want the
roots to be fully accustomed to the
native soils because the soil is only
going to get worse the further down this
tree goes more compaction more clay
and
so we want to keep all the nutrients on
top for more long-term weed suppression
i like to plant in support species and
one of my favorite plants to
help support establishing trees is
comfrey semphitim officinale so we'll
just take a few of these roots and we'll
tuck them right into this compost around
the top
and this way
instead of having
weeds that compete for nutrients
we'll have comfrey pulling up the
nutrients and then we can come back and
chop off those leaves and use them for
further weed suppression and one thing
to keep in mind is you don't need
comfrey um but it's really nice to have
so if you can get your hand some your
hands on some comfrey you can get it
really inexpensively and it's really
going to help with the success of the
trees if you can do it absolutely and
other great support species include
stinging nettle yarrow
and anything that establishes a dense
ground cover underneath the base of your
tree
so next up we're gonna go with mulch
after the compost is mulch and
there's a lot of free ways to get mulch
one of the easiest is leaves these are
just leaves that we raked up today
and then another one is wood chips wood
chips and you can find this as a free
product as well as well so
either one is good
so we've done about a five gallon bucket
of leaves and a five gallon bucket of uh
wood chips and there's a couple really
important reasons why you want to do
this it's weed suppression
it is moisture retention to reduce the
possibility of these being damaged by
drought
it's also creating fertility all of this
breaks down into fertility building soil
one thing just other thing to mention is
that you'll notice that it's almost more
about what's above the hole than what's
below the hole so
you can get by with less but doing this
is gonna really ensure the success of
these trees yeah so now that we've added
all this organic matter and compost and
wood chips we've brought the level up
well above the collar so we want to be
sure to push all of that away
to where
the
collar is not at all getting buried by
or by our organic matter and mulching
and a really simple way i like to
remember that is donut not volcano
that's what i learned as a beginner
planter so you'll see we've kind of
created a donut and some people they
plant up into a volcano and you don't
want to do the volcano you always want
to have a donut
so yeah now the next step is to make
sure that this beautiful baby tree
doesn't get munched to death by the deer
as soon as it starts putting out leaves
in the spring so we're gonna need some
kind of protection deer are
the animal that are most likely to eat
your plants that you're protecting them
against but
eric what what other animals are we
protecting against with these protectors
um well there's certainly groundhogs can
be formidable foes when the trees are
young
even up to head high they'll pull down a
flexible sapling and eat every leaf off
of it
there are a number of different rodents
that will
chew off the bark and
suck sap out of the tree until it dies
and so that's why i like to rely on
hardware cloth rather than chicken wire
if i'm going to be making my own tree
tubes and i because chicken wire the
holes are bigger and those rodents those
rodents can get right in and out it's
like an open door for them but this
hardware cloth is too small for most any
rodent to get through
and these are going to be on for about
at least two years yeah a minimum of two
years so they're going to be on there
for a while so you got to stake them in
eric's going to show us
uh using the hardware cloth first and
when he says planter this is actually a
specific brand that you can buy and it's
one that you recommend yeah it's one
that we've been using for a couple years
at plant path and it's working out well
so far
but there's other sources of purchasing
these as well
absolutely and some of them are just uh
smaller you know so they'll be only two
feet tall like this hardware cloth
and that's fine because
as the tree gets taller you can just put
a second
layer of hardware cloth on
to prevent deer from nibbling your
leaves
and so we've got the the hardware cloth
around and then we would just want to
secure this
to the
um to the stake yeah and to do that i
typically use some kind of heavy duty
twist tie
and like you can see this one
is pretty thick and double wired
but there's also fencing wire that you
can buy very inexpensively
simple as that so next up is the tree
tube
yep and so we just
very simply
take the twist ties off
and we
carefully
tuck the tree into the tube
so now your tree is planted has weed
suppression fertility and protection
from the animals all that's left to keep
in mind is the watering
when these trees are bare root and
they're just getting established you're
going to want to make sure that they get
water at least twice a week by planting
in the spring or fall time
you kind of ensure that the weather is
going to take care of most of the
watering for you
but if you live in a drier climate
you're going to want to keep an eye on
that and in the middle of long hot
summers you want to check on your trees
regularly to see if the leaves are
starting to wilt or droop at all that
generally takes about 10 days at 75 plus
degrees and it's always good to go and
visit your trees as often as possible
because
as some of my great gardening friends
often say the best fertilizer is the
gardener's shadow so spend lots of time
with your trees
and love i mean that's the same thing
it's like being here loving them
spending time with them
it's the it's the reason we're planting
these trees so make sure that you're
visiting them um ideally you're adding
composted mulch at least once a year
yeah yeah at least once a year and you
can definitely do it twice a year and
weeding to keep this area
uh you know clean so that the trees
don't have competition
and spending time with them is
absolutely key so we're really excited
for you to plant your community fruit
and nut trees and we are so appreciative
for you being a part of this now this
covered really what you need to know but
we cover everything at
communityfruittrees.org and you can also
email us for that one-to-one
communication and support to have things
uh
to ensure the success of your trees so
we love you
happy growing with your community fruit
and nut trees
and we want to see your trees as soon as
you have planted them so send us little
videos send us photos so that we can
spread the abundance and spread the love
for community fruit and nut trees
congratulations to all of you on
receiving your community fruit and nut
trees this is a very exciting time
so much good food to come in your
community now if you can't plant your
trees right away which probably most of
you won't you have to heal them in to
store them temporarily so i'm going to
show you how to do that it's super
simple it's basically just burying them
in the soil for the short term until you
can plant them so you have your trees
here are
the bare root trees
and a couple of quick important things
you want to keep these roots protected
that's the purpose
and in between taking them out and
putting them in the ground you also want
to keep them protected avoid exposing
them to sunlight as much as possible and
then secondly keep them out in the air
for as little time as possible from when
you're transferring them to when you are
healing them in so it's really important
to protect the roots roots don't spend
time in the sunlight and air they like
to be underground so healing them in is
really simple and it comes down to just
digging a hole or a trench so i'm gonna
do that
so i've dug a hole very simple nothing
fancy whatsoever
i grab my trees and they can stay
in their bunch just like this
set them in there
leaning is totally fine
and then
just cover them up with that dirt
and then simply step on there gently
just to kind of
make them nice and snug in there just a
gentle step not all of your weight
and they are now
stored that's going to keep them safe
until you can go ahead and plant them
you could let them sit here
for you know days couple weeks but
definitely get them planted as soon as
you can to start the community fruit nut
tree journey we're excited to be on this
journey with all of you and uh excited
to see these grow these trees growing
and producing a bounty of food for your
community in the years to come